There he is.
[Music]
We have to tune our poses, right?
I think we were following the one we took from the store.
We wanted to do something before we left.
[Music]
So, basically jumping up on the sales.
Right.
[Music]
Well, at least we can't really go a lot like this, right?
Me and Chaco.
Prepare something during these times and I'll unfill the flag.
Ha!
Yes.
Oh!
Can't really go in saving people.
But I don't know now, can we?
It's perfect.
You're looking at it with my eyes.
Wait, we're finally getting our wrong flag.
Yes.
Open your eyes.
Oh yeah, right.
I had them closed.
It's the rip, waving goodbye there.
[Music]
When you got dropped.
That's that I promise.
[Music]
I'm going to leave a message for you to take care of yourself.
And I'll give this a spare flag witness to hang out.
I'll give this a spare flag to you.
[Music]
But I know it doesn't move or close to a
bring up democrats power
I mean if the dog wants to come I know he doesn't always like to come.
Not a 15.
As long as problem.
Are you foreshadowing something?
Can this dog swim? Stroke with the water?
I don't know.
Are you better?
Are you the oldest of the brothers or?
I don't know.
Wonderful.
I...
We need some assistance and materials if you wouldn't mind helping.
I'll help you.
I'll just...
We need these items to reinforce the cage for our pet bees.
I also like to make a...
It also has maintenance.
This is a saber tube tiger.
That means you will do it.
What you said here is your blood or no blood?
And what makes you believe that I am not a local?
What the fuck? A fence taken?
Well this one over here, personal night and I like point towards Bob.
And this is a...
A Bob quickly...
Like, make sure to like use his handkerchief to like hide the blood in his mouth.
And this one pointed to my office is a relative who holds a high position in my angle.
Sort of like an advisor.
What's the price?
You might overestimate your own capabilities.
I know you said you were the best of the fathers, but...
In your brother wasn't so expensive and he was pretty mediocre.
I think it's better if you...well take a look instead.
Freedom for the people.
Freedom for the people is just the outcome that we managed to come to.
He wanted us to steal something and use the blackmail him.
I genuinely don't remember.
No, I think it was cheaper than that.
Thank you.
No.
I think he went a little cheaper than 20 million.
Thank you.
It's a million berries, you said.
It makes some time to arrange, but when do you need it by the end?
I'll be back.
You're back.
Or am I foundry's stopped working?
Oh.
Foundry died.
I'll just listen to it.
We were just stopping mile on the island and we needed assistance from the ship right here.
But he requires this too much for me to handle up front so I have to go make arrangements to get it done.
But...
Well, I'm from Noble Origins and I've been traveling with a sport in the people.
You see my kingdom?
We just got through a rebellion.
And we need to rebuild.
We need more support to speak.
So I'm going to tap with the relegator.
It's an island not too far from here actually.
I can't open my notes to see what island we just came from.
The kingdom of decibel.
Like I said, we just got through a rebellion in the process of rebuilding.
My family was a forgotten house.
We were one of the original houses.
We were shipped, well not shipped but fell to ruin.
But through helping in the rebellion we returned to our rightful position.
We are from the lunar house.
They call me the lunar stopper.
I didn't open it.
This site isn't loading for me.
Hold on.
Is there a new link compared to the first one you ever...
That's my wife.
It's not.
Is anybody else able to join it?
It crashed again for me.
The original registered from Argotino.
Yes.
I can understand.
Was my decision modified?
That's a lot better here.
I don't know if it's a new one.
It doesn't matter.
Did you not listen to my story?
I said we were one of the original houses.
I had a tell from it.
Why do you think we helped with the rebellion against him?
We were one of the original houses.
This is my night and this is my relative.
I'm going to go with him.
I'll go with him.
I have a better view.
We will get rid of the writers instead.
We will get rid of the writers.
I overheard you had the rain.
Are you a businessman or are you a mayor?
I'm a mayor.
I feel something can be arranged.
How long have these people been raised?
Would that be more arranged for you?
Yes, back on.
Okay, that's just loading from here right now.
Okay, that's just loading from here.
Sounds like a plan.
Okay, I'm still not able to open up.
Okay, I'm using my old to be honest.
Did you see that one in the general work?
Okay, there we go.
I'm one less.
Okay, that's just loading from here.
That's just loading from here.
What?
Okay, I'll just say thank you.
Okay, the map is not that big this far.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, that's fair.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, big guy.
Could you leave us alone with the woman, please?
Leave the way.
Okay, thank you.
Just some.
You go first, we go clear out the scape root.
Okay, thank you.
Cut down the edge.
What the hell?
Okay, thank you.
Okay, let's swing in stand this shit.